when you hear the term conservation you
might think of wildlife or land
preservation but what about the things
that we eat DeMarco Morgan is here to
tell us about how a group of renowned
chefs is focusing on responsible
ingredients demarco good morning good
morning to you right now we rely on just
one percent of available crops to fuel
our diets and experts say that could put
the future of our food system at risk
last week some leaders in the restaurant
industry got together at Google offices
here in New York and they wanted to shed
light on lesser-known crops
an effort to encourage a more diverse
and delicious future breadfruit Tiki
chef tacos and fonio salad the
ingredients and these dishes may sound
strange but Eric Oberholtzer thinks they
could be the next big thing there was a
time that we can remember maybe 10 or 15
years ago where nobody knew what quinoa
is now it's everywhere Asahi was this
esoteric very from the Amazon now there
are whole concepts called Asahi bull so
we believe that we're going to present
the next acai and next quinoa tonight
and you'll see in five years ten or
fonio or breadfruit might be everywhere
and that would be a great success OPA
hope sir found success by focusing on
sustainability at the restaurant chain
tender greens now he wants his fellow
chefs to introduce more diverse
ingredients a way to ensure food
security for the future
that's why oberholt helped to cook up
the food forever experience featuring
overlooked fruit vegetables and grains
his partner was Marie Haga
the executive director of crop trust
over many years scientists have secured
millions of samples of crop varieties
and gene banks an international
organization working to safeguard
agriculture so you to believe that we
can end hunger with the crops in the
food that we have now more than 50%
should we eat come from four crops this
makes us extremely vulnerable so one of
the things that we are trying to do now
is to introduce more diversity into this
food system it's a way to make food sexy
again super sexy and delicious and
relatable and affordable and accessible
and every one of us has an opportunity
three times a day to participate in this
movement and part of who and what we are
it can be also told through the story of
our seeds and the plants and the
influences of all these ingredients so
there's this magical world to discover
much of that magic is rooted in the past
you can see here butter lettuce butter
head from France 1775 that's when those
seeds were saved
these plants having been grown or tasted
since then 1775 that's right a
hydroponic system fitted with grow
lights brought these antique greens into
the 21st century it's all about flavor
and if we can grow them right by our
kitchen then it doesn't have to be
transported anywhere crop trust guards
about 1 million varieties of seeds in
this mountain in 12 rod Norway as seen
on Sunday morning last year the Doomsday
vault is the backup for 1700 seed banks
worldwide in the event of some future
apocalypse
according to crop trust there are 30,000
edible plant species but we only eat
about 150 of them many of those
forgotten crops have high nutritional
value and are resilient even in the face
of climate change like temporary beans
which farmers have grown in the
southwest for centuries and are one of
the most drought tolerant foods in the
world you have something that doesn't
suck up so much water which is an
important resource in California others
joined in to create futuristic dishes
including veteran chef Lord Cardos this
Frankie was filled with a spicy
jackfruit students set on a bed of
Emirate and ancient gluten-free grain I
believe it's my job
reduce people to ingredients and they
don't know and it's my job to show
people that you don't only need to eat
say be underline every single day there
are the cuts from the arrow there are
other grains
besides wheat and rice I like chef Umbra
Maude came up with a pudding cake using
dates and Kansa a causative wheat that
is perennial and can prevent erosion
Jordi the populations under the age of
40 the majority of the population is not
exposed to places that have arable land
and water so we can create these crops
and we can inspire other people to use
them in different ways that will become
a movement and people will get fed all
right let's try it I'm ready the chef's
prude planted the seeds for a more
sustainable future can be delicious my
mission was to bring good food to
everybody and and now it's really that
everybody is not just the 99% in Los
Angeles or New York this everybody on
the planet through crowd sourcing
through influence through inspiration
through this movement we can inspire
other like-minded chefs and their
farmers and their audience their diners
to participate in in a way that makes
sense to them and like that we can truly
bring good food to everybody on the
planet and if we do that while taking
care of the planet we've done something
amazing and that gets me out of bed
every morning now all of this is in
support of the United Nations I should
say goal to end hunger by the year 2030
and the organisers hope to take the food
forever experience around the entire
wards and I got to be honest with you
guys from you think about preparing for
the future you think about going green
or buying eco-friendly products you
never think about the future of food
yeah this is a good thing well and I can
tell it's good buy the big bites you
were taking it's pretty tasty I'll
produce a video she wanted me to try the
creek is what I was like nah
[Laughter]